when you say perky meat what are we
talking about i'm serving that perky me
if they got the feet you know i'm like
you know bigelow around this
[ __ ] i've never done um
i've only smoked weed and done shrooms
never done any pills i only do drugs
that people prescribe and that people
can um that's actually tested and that
you can do outside like i said i do
drugs that we can do on live not that we
gotta hide i've heard uh though
there's something about having sex on
percocet yeah wearing [ __ ] out off
the park she's like oh stop oh god oh
here keep going i got a bonus for you
yeah is it like kind of like doing a
bike because it's like on some viagra
[ __ ]
i mean it's just like a perk but like
it's just a perk to me a perk is just
like
i guess you can say it is but
i don't do the perk for that type of
[ __ ] i just see what i'm saying it's all
about the music again are you ever
worried about uh
you know the fentanyl [ __ ] getting the
wrong batch [ __ ] yeah i got a couple
heads on the roster you know i'm saying
other than that uh we ain't doing no no
fenty's no pressies yeah i saw like now
people are one that had fetty wap
now people are uh they don't even want
they want they no give me the fentanyl
yeah that's what i'm not eating
this [ __ ] is wild out here bro
it's like [ __ ] are smoking
fentanyl like it's normal yeah like it's
just a thing
super crackheads is what i call them
like if you're gonna do like all that
type of [ __ ] you better all doing
shrooms like i'll be trying to tell
people if you to just
act like you want to go to another power
then just take some stronger you're
going to be out you know i'm saying
don't be like overdo it just kind of
micro dose into that [ __ ] stop hitting
10 micro dos a little more you know sin
but don't most people would do strums
and just like oh it's not hitting me
well take more you gotta eat more